yeah so in 2007 i was 13 years old
and we didn't have anything to eat
anymore
so we were thinking what do we do you
know there were tons of people dying
from starvation
and i was fortunate enough to live on
the border town of north korea
so i was able to see the lights coming
from china side
so if you look at the satellite photos
of north korea it is like the literally
darkest place on earth
you don't have interest interested at
nights so i was looking at china and
then wondering
maybe if i go where the lights or i
might find something to eat
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today
is a human rights activist author of in
order to live
a north korean girl's journey to freedom
and someone that
i'm honored to call a friend yanbi park
welcome to the reuben report thank you
so much for having me it's a real honor
to be on your show
i'm thrilled to have you can i call us
friends we've only hung out one time
just in the last few weeks but i i feel
that we are long-lost friends
definitely i've been following you're
almost like stuck in here for last three
four years
i've been to your show with the joe
jordan peters in chicago
and i was in one of the audience so yeah
nice well i i do consider you a friend
and i'm thrilled you're here because
your story
is is just absolutely
incredible and you've become a fighter
for so many of the things that that this
show is about
so let's just start at the beginning for
for people that
that don't know you uh let's just let's
just do your biography just
just tell me your story and then we'll
go from there
right yeah so i was born in the northern
part of north korea
in end of 1993 so that was
right after soviet union collapsed and
north korean regime stopped providing
russian to the people
so because in the socialist system you
know if
the trading is illegal and if the
government doesn't give you food
what do you do you starve to death and
unfortunately that's when i was born
when north korea began
going into this thing called like the
you know i mean the worst family in
human history in 21st century
i was born in north korea i had a father
my mom and my sister in a very ordinary
household
and i had no clue that north korea was a
you know hermit kingdom or weird country
it's
we are truly isolated you don't even
know what isolation means
and growing up in north korea of course
it was a you know we didn't have word
for love we didn't have a word for
liberty we didn't have word for a lot
about things
so it you were 13 when
your family decided to leave north korea
is that right
yeah that's i mean gay from north korea
it wasn't like you're
getting a passport yeah right escape
escape is a much better word so can you
just uh tell us a little bit about what
that was like
yeah so in 2007 i was 13 years old
and we didn't have anything to eat
anymore
so we were thinking what do we do you
know there are tons of people dying from
starvation
and i was fortunate enough to live on
the border town of north korea
so i was able to see the lights coming
from china side
so if you look at the satellite photos
of north korea it is like the literally
darkest place on earth
you don't have interesting nights so i
was looking
at china and then wondering maybe if i
go where the lights were
i might find something to eat and that
was a motivation
why we risked our life to escape from
china i mean north korea
yeah and your story of of actually how
you did it is pretty incredible so
you have to tell that to everybody where
we
i was we had to cross the frozen river
to china
and there are like every 10 meters the
border guards with
machine guns now the north korea buried
the land mines and electrified the wire
fences to prevent people to stay
however when we were escaping we had a
person
a human trafficker he sold us to chinese
human traffickers
and that's how we were able to safely
cross the border to china
and did you guys know what was gonna
happen to you i mean i know you were
just a kid but
did your parents at that point know
you're being sold to human traffickers
and i know you'll you'll tell what
happened next
but did your parents have any idea what
that meant or or it was just like we
have to get there no matter what is
about to happen to us
so it wasn't like my parents deciding it
my sister
escaped a few days before me and i was
in the hospital
and you know in north korean hospitals
you don't of course have x-rays or
nothing
the doctor just like you know touched my
tummy and told me
you might have some bursting of appendix
and we have to operate on you this
afternoon and
they of course cut my belly without any
anesthesia
and they realized it wasn't like
appendix it was just
malnutrition and infection so i couldn't
go with my sister
but she left me a note to say go find
this lady
and she will help you to go to china and
when i saw that letter i told my mom
like mom you gotta come with me
i couldn't give my father who was very
sick so
it was uh i took my mom to me and you
mirror crossing that river
we didn't even know the word human
trafficking like it wasn't something a
concept i was aware
right i think it's like i didn't even
question why the person was helping
us i was so desperate you know it wasn't
didn't really matter if
if i was gonna get killed in china my
faith in north korea was death anyway
so really matter what it was yeah do you
think your mom knew
what what was about to happen when you
got there to china
no clue she also had abs so in north
korea we don't we have like one channel
on tv
which is all propaganda and we don't
have internet
and there is only we don't like i have
one newspaper
we do not have any outside information
coming in
so i never even seen the map of the
world i had no clue
the different ways existed i did not
even know what africa was
you know in north korea the regime told
me that i was keeming some race
they didn't tell me that i was asian so
you know i didn't really know
how many countries existed or none of
the outside north korea
so sure of course did not know we just
went there
and found out what it was yeah okay so
you get to china
and i think you probably thought you
were
gonna be safe but that's not exactly how
that worked out either
yeah so i was 13 and crossing this
frozen river with mom and the
human trafficker helping us to go there
and as soon as the first thing
i was saying was my mom raped in front
of me
and i was 13 and in north korea we don't
have any sex education
so i didn't even need you know what that
was didn't even know that was a rape
just
horrible and i couldn't believe what was
happening and then they told us later
you know they were like negotiating our
price in front of us
now they talk about slave markets
exactly like that they sort of my mom
for
around 65 dollars in 21st century right
now
and i was above 200 they bought me
because i was a virgin and i was young
and they sold us separately to different
human traffickers
right and then what i feel like this
whole interview i could just say to you
and then what and then what because it's
such a it's such a series of things but
i think it's important for people to
really understand all these steps
so as soon as they were separating mom
and me
and you know even i was like 13 minor
didn't care they were like
they wanted to make more money out of us
and splitting us
they tore restored me to another human
trafficker he was like
han chinese and he
of course tried to break me and i was
trying to kill myself
i was i couldn't take it anymore so i
was trying to kill myself and he said
you know if i become his mistress and
he would become buying my mom and bring
my family to me
i was in a way very lucky that i found
the trafficker who wanted to help me
that way
so at thursday i thought like okay if i
become his mistress i can
save my family and i did become his
mistress he raped me
and did bring my mom back he bought my
mom from the farmer he started to
so because of the due to one child
policy
in china right now there are more than
30 million men cannot find wives
north korean women are are demanded by
these men
and sold as a sexual slave stem
did you think your life was better at
that point
like did you feel better now suddenly
you had seen a wider world but
horrific things were happening to you i
mean the rape of your mom rape of you
you were it's not that you were free
like what did you think at the time in
terms of like was
were things better was it worth going
i stopped feeling things i think
through my therapy that's like my
struggle by not trying to feel again
like at 13 somehow i just learned not to
fear
so it was like i was thinking about am i
happier like it was like that was like
every second of a survivor and trying to
not get caught by chinese authority
because they were like
looking for us like every second if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell